welcome back everyone
so this is already the last uh talk of
the reinforcement learning summer school
and um
i want to thank um because before i
introduce our next speaker i want to
thank
the organization around this event um
really it's been a pleasure to host
this event along with the seafarer staff
so thank you to jackie
thank you thank you to yeah um wendy as
well as
nadine from mila who's been uh helping
us to prepare this event
throughout the last uh six eight weeks
actually
so um really without them uh none of the
logistical
uh none of the logistics would work out
around this event
um aaron and i were only here for for
basically the program
and and we just had the privilege to
pick up to pick the speaker list
so thanks a lot and i also wanted just
to say
that i i hope that um we've succeeded in
making you feel part of our community
um i really believe that that science is
not something that
that belongs to select few it really
belongs to all of us
and and it's our it's our job as
scientists to challenge assumptions
and to provide new ways of thinking and
seeing the world so that's why we need
new people
and i feel like just quoting actually
our
good colleague uh from montreal uh
who's actually leading uh the deepmind
team in montreal who
once told me that he thinks that for him
the greatest innovation in the ai over
the last
few years was not so much algorithmic
but the fact that there's such
a big influx of new researchers in our
field that for him
this is the the big game changer in our
field that we're gonna have
so many new ways of thinking about our
field that is completely gonna change it
and i think this is really true i think
that this is our best asset
and and our best tools for your future
is to come up with new perspective
and new ways of understanding our
problem
and that's really how we're going to be
able to solve the ai's greatest
challenges and also how we're gonna have
the most impact in our society
um so with that
i would say uh uh thank you for
participating let's hope to see you
at some point in milan montreal and now
um let me introduce you uh chelsea finn
who's our last speaker of our session so
today we've heard from angela and rupam
and different ways to apply
reinforcement learning on real systems
and i think that the common topic among
all these talks was
was the importance of data efficiency in
real world systems
and this is a constraint that is super
important as well when you have safety
constraints
um so today we're going to see probably
a third approach a
an approach that chelsea has been
pushing
and is the it's the approach of meta
learning and reinforcement learning it's
gained a lot of interest
from her uh initial work in 2017
and since then it's really create a new
field and so chelsea finn is an
assistant professor in the computer
science department at stanford she's
also a cfair fellow
she received the acm 2018 doctoral
dissertation award for her thesis
and more recently she's also received
the microsoft faculty fellowship award
so i can say without hesitation that
chelsea's work
has truly pushed your field in new
directions and i'm very happy to welcome
her
chelsea thank you for the introduction
i'm excited to be here too uh and hope
to
hope that you learned something through
um through what i'll talk about today
um and actually let me make sure that i
can see the participants
so the um if you have any questions
throughout
this i'd encourage you to raise your
hands and i'll pause at a few points
during the lecture
uh to take your questions uh so that
this can hopefully be a little bit more
interactive
than uh simply me talking at you
um yeah so today i'm going to be talking
about meta reinforcement learning
and first i want to give some motivation
for uh why we we want to
do something like my learning so
uh to start off i'm actually going to
give you a little test
um the answer you can kind of keep to
yourself or write down on a piece of
paper or something
um since we we aren't in person
uh but the test is what is as follows so
i'm going to give you a training data
set these are
your training data set is the six images
on the left
and you want to be able to classify the
image on the right
and in particular the left most three
images
are paintings that were painted by brock
and
the second column are three paintings
that were painted by
cezanne and now your goal is from these
six
images in your training data set can you
classify
the painting on the right as being from
brock or cezanne
um so i'll give you a second to think
about this
um and look at the kind of the training
data and learn from the training data
how to kind of
classify this new image um
and hopefully the answer that you
most most of you came up with is uh
brock that's the correct answer
and you can tell that by the kind of
style of painting and the kind of
straighter lines that you see in um in
the paintings by brock and also the
paintings in the test example
now how did you accomplish this task
so uh you only had six training examples
and yet you were able to actually or
usually i hope
many of you are able to classify the
image on the right
and the way that you accomplish this is
you have previous experience
um and maybe you haven't seen these
particular paintings before maybe you
actually haven't even seen paintings
from these painters before
but you have previous experience looking
at images and you aren't
starting from scratch tabula rasa to
learn this task
and so kind of the key idea behind
metal learning that i'll talk about
today is can we enable systems
to leverage previous experience in a way
that allows them to learn from such a
small
amount of data and
in particular we'll be talking about
reinforcement learning and
uh humans are kind of remarkably good at
reinforcement learning
for the same reason so you can see kind
of kids can learn how to kind of stack
objects on top of each other in certain
orders and so forth
without kind of a lot of trial and error
experience
and the reason is it for this is that
people also have previous experience
when they're learning different tasks
like
different motor control tasks
so if we want to build a machine
learning system that's as efficient and
can learn from just
six examples or a few examples we need
to figure out how we can leverage
some previous experience about the world
so how might we do this um
if you of course if you just train a
neural network from scratch on this date
on this task you'll do
pretty poorly uh and so
if you are thinking about how to get a
machine to accomplish this task
uh there's a few different ways you
could go um and that kind of if you were
thinking about this a long time ago
uh one kind of classic approach in
computer vision was to provide some
prior knowledge in the form of a
model of the image formation process uh
if you kind of move forward
maybe a decade uh the approaches were
more like providing information about
geometry as prior knowledge
um then more recently people were
looking at things like sift features and
hog features
as prior knowledge um or maybe you would
kind of
pre-train from imagenet and fine-tune
from those features or do domain
adaptation from other painters
and each of these kind of things in this
list
are different ways of injecting prior
knowledge or
prior experience into
machine learning systems and into kind
of ai systems
now one of the things you might notice
is that uh kind of as you go down this
list
fewer of the prior knowledge is coming
from
human knowledge and they're becoming
increasingly more
data-driven priors uh and also arguably
the the things towards the bottom of
this
of this list have achieved greater
success than some of the approaches at
the top
so this suggests that maybe we should
move in the direction of building in
priors that are acquired from data and
from previous experience
when trying to learn new tasks
and perhaps at the extreme of this is
thinking about if we can try to
explicitly learn priors from previous
data and previous experience
that lead to efficient downstream
learning and this is kind of the key
idea behind
metal learning essentially can we learn
how to learn
from previous experience so that when we
have a new downstream task we can learn
that
very efficiently okay so that's the high
level
motivation behind metal learning and
today i'll be talking about
specifically the meta reinforcement
learning problem statement
um and so i'll first go over kind of the
problem formulation and some examples
then i'll talk about two primary methods
for
solving the meta reinforcement learning
problem um then i'll talk about
the learning to explore problem which is
kind of a key component of meta
reinforcement learning
and i'll talk i'll end by talking about
some open problems in meta rl and some
of the kind of latest developments and
challenges
okay so let's get started with talking
about actually the problem formulation
and some examples of meta reinforcement
learning problems
so before we move go to the meta
reinforced learning problem let's first
just look at the meta learning problem
and to do this we can start with kind of
defining some notation in the context of
supervised learning
so in supervised learning you might have
inputs x and outputs
y and you want to learn a function that
maps from x to y
maybe parametrized by theta and the way
that you learn this is through data of
input output pairs
now the idea behind metal learning is
that we're essentially going to nest
uh nest this problem a bit so in the
meta supervised learning case
our goal is basically to solve the
problem that you saw on the second slide
which is you're given this little
training data set
which consists of k input output pairs
so in the k shot learning case you have
k of these input output pairs in your
training data set
and using this data you want to then
classify
a new input x test
to produce the corresponding label y
test
so you can essentially view the metal
learning problem in the context of
supervised learning
as learning this mapping from a training
data set and a new input
to the corresponding label
the way you go about training or kind of
learning
such a learning procedure this function
f can be viewed as a learning procedure
as it's learning from
or taking in data learning from that
data and classifying a new input
the way that you go about doing this is
you have data that's in the form of
different data sets um so you have data
sets for different tasks
each of these data sets has a number of
input output pairs
and typically for each of these tasks
you assume that you have at least
k examples so that you can sample k
samples to be used for d
train and at least one example to be
used to measure whether
your learner generalized to that task
and then you train this across a number
of different tasks denoted as di
okay so that's kind of notationally what
the problem looks like and this
this view on metal learning is actually
pretty nice and useful because it
essentially reduces
the problem of metal learning to the
design and optimization of this function
f
essentially if we can design a good
function that can take us and put some
data
and also optimize this function then we
have
a learning procedure that we can apply
to new tasks
so now let's look at an example of what
this actually looks like
so a canonical example in metal learning
is
fushot classification this is very
similar to the problem that you saw on
the second slide
where you're given this training data
set in this case your training data set
has
one example of five different classes
and then your goal is to classify new
images as being among
those five classes so
basically kind of the same kind of
problem that you saw previously with the
paintings
and the way that you go about solving
this is
let's say you have data from other image
classes from image classes that are
other
other than lines and bowls and so forth
and you try to structure that data
in a way that matches what you're going
to be seeing at test time
which is exactly this q shot learning
problem
in particular if you can take five other
image classes shown here
kind of break it up into a little train
set and a little test set
and do this for multiple sets
of five classes train your function
across these train your your med learner
across these training classes to take as
input a training data set
and produce uh correct labels on each
task
test set um essentially learning how to
learn each of these tasks
so that at test time you've been given
these images
you can effectively classify them even
if these classes are
different from any of the classes that
you saw during metatrading
okay um and so that's this is kind of an
example but
in reality any any of these tasks shown
in each of these rows could be
other learning problems they don't have
to be classification problems
you could be trying to learn some
regression problem or trying to predict
um the dynamics of a robot for different
tasks
there's lots of different ways that you
could structure these tasks
the key thing is that you want this test
task shown at the top
to be to be kind of
representative of the kinds of tasks
that you're training it on
okay so now that we've looked at the
meta supervised learning problem what
about the meta reinforcement learning
problem
um the way that this looks is we're
basically just going to replace each of
those rows
with reinforcement learning problems
instead of um
instead of supervised learning problems
so uh
instead of having a supervised learning
problem as shown here we're going to
replace our inputs
x with our states s produce our outputs
replace our outputs with actions a
and then our goal is to learn a policy
pi that maps from states to actions
using uh some state action reward next
state transitions
so this is kind of one way to view the
reinforcement learning problem
where your goal is to learn pi such that
you maximize your expected rewards
and the way that we can kind of turn
this into a better reinforcement
learning problem
is again we're going to be trying to
learn from a small amount of data
such that for example this the small
amount of data may be
k rollouts from some policy we want to
learn from this such that when given a
new state
we can effectively predict a good action
to take from that state
and so you could again view this as some
function or some learner f
that takes as input this training data
set that it's trying to learn from this
is kind of its
experience in its current task as well
as the current state and predicts
the corresponding action and again
the data that we'll have will be a data
set of data sets
where each data set corresponds to a
different task
and each data set is collected
for different tasks okay
so here the problem is also the design
and optimization of this function f
how it's actually going to learn uh how
it's going to actually learn from this
data and how we're going to optimize it
to learn from this data
but another important part about the
meta reinforcement learning problem
is how to collect appropriate data
basically how to collect
dtrain because this is also in your
control in a reinforcement learning
setting as well
uh essentially this this part of that
problem is the learning to explore part
like figuring out how you should collect
this training data
um how to explore for a new task such
that that
data gives you effective information for
solving the task
okay um so kind of as a concrete example
uh one thing we might want to do is
maybe we want to solve figure out how to
navigate a maze
from some examples so given a small
amount of experience in one maze
you want to figure out how to solve that
maze
and the way that you do this is this is
kind of what happens
this is meta test time the way that you
do this is during meta training time
you learn how to learn many other mazes
um so you give it kind of experience in
this maze
create it to solve this maze with a
small amount of data and
and so forth okay
um one final note about
the meta reinforcement learning problem
is before i mentioned that this d
train could be k rollouts from some
policy
this is kind of the episodic variant of
meta reinforcement learning
a more online variant could be one where
this training data set corresponds to
just a kind of a few time steps of from
your policy and you're trying to
essentially learn on the fly from this
data
just in kind of a matter of time steps
rather than from multiple rollouts
okay i'll pause here to see if there are
any questions
on the problem statement before moving
on to the methods
so feel free to raise your hand if you
have a question i also
see that there's some q a
[Music]
that we could also go to toga do you
want to ask your question
um thank you um to my understanding when
we uh
remember formalizing the meta learning
problem early on
to me kind of felt like we were just
doing a transfer learning on on a number
of different batches so
i i'm not sure how what would you say
would be the significant differences
between a classical
transfer learning or just
mini-batch-based learning versus
meta-learning tasks yeah that's a good
question
so in um because the transfer learning
problem and the meta learning problem
are very similar
i think that where things differ the
most are
in actually how the algorithms are
derived and
specifically you can view metal learning
approaches as ones that explicitly
optimize for good transfer performance
they kind of explicitly optimized for
performance
for learning on different tasks so that
you can learn a new task quickly
whereas transfer learning approaches
often use
they may not often kind of explicitly
optimize for that fast
adaptation performance for example by
by optimizing for like features to be
overlapping or something they use kind
of more hand-coded mechanisms to try to
enable good transfer
okay um i don't
i can also try to see if i um
see the q a yeah so another question is
it seems like my supervised learning is
similar to semi-supervised learning
um so i guess one thing that i'll
mention is that typically
the data sets that you see are
when you have a data set of data sets we
typically assume that those
each of those data sets from previous
tasks has the corresponding labels
so we're not actually using any
unlabeled data in this context
we're using kind of batches of data from
different tasks
okay cool so
um i'll hold off on questions for now
um and we'll talk about some of the
metal learning methods and if some of
these questions are still
um if people still have some of these
questions after going through the
methods then we can uh
we can definitely talk about those as
well
oh actually one question that i'll ask
quickly they'll answer quickly is
someone uh
maddie asks do you train on all tasks
simultaneously or sequentially
a standard metal learning setup will
assume that you train on
typically you're allowed to access all
of the tasks at once rather than
the tasks and sequence although although
there are some meta learning
problem statements where you actually
only get the tasks in sequence
and many of the algorithms that i'll
discuss today can also be applied
to that sequential setting as well
okay so let's talk about some of the
method classes for actually solving this
problem
uh and there's really two primary
classes that are used in the context of
meta reinforcement learning
um and so once you kind of understand
these two primary classes then you
you'll understand kind of most of
meta-rl
so in the problem statement i talked
about
this um i talked about how we want to
kind of
have this function that takes its input
a training data set and a state and
outputs the next state
or outputs the corresponding action um
and so one really simple
way to do this is to essentially
parameterize this
learner with just a big neural network
so for example it could be a recurrent
neural network that
takes as input the data sequentially
um and outputs an action
uh and that's basically it you could
have different structures as well this
doesn't necessarily need to be recurrent
you could use an attention based model
you could use temporal convolutions um
you could use something that just kind
of takes as input all the data and then
aggregates them and then produces kind
of a context there's a lot of different
things you could choose for the
architecture here
but the key thing is that we're just
going to parameterize f with this big
neural network
that takes as input the data um as well
as
the current state and outputs uh the
action for that state
uh and note that this kind of takes as
input the reward at the previous time
step
which is pretty important if you want to
be able to adapt to different reward
functions
now you might ask well how does this
compare to just doing reinforcement
learning with the recurrent policy
uh and it's quite similar with a couple
with
well one change is that you're passing
in rewards into this policy
whereas typically in like if you just
apply a recurrent policy you may not be
passing rewards
but the bigger difference is that the
hidden state of your
recurrent network is actually maintained
across episodes within a task
and so this allows you to actually adapt
to a task across multiple episodes
and kind of maintain memory about that
task and kind of learn about that task
across multiple multiple episodes
okay um so that's kind of the gist of of
this approach it's
quite simple and you could optimize this
this function with standard
reinforcement learning methods
with like policy gradient methods or
with q learning like methods
and so i'll highlight just one case
study of using this kind of approach
which is a paper back in 2018 on
using a mix of attention basically using
attention-based models and
convolution-based models
for this uh metal learner
and in particular what the architecture
looked like is they trained a policy
that looks like this
where they take in the state at each
time step as well as the action from the
previous time step
and the reward from the previous time
step the architecture interleaves
1d convolutions and attention mechanisms
and at each time step kind of outputs
the corresponding action
you then execute that action and then
observe the reward and pass in the
that reward and the action at the next
time step
so that's uh that's kind of
the gist of the method and they trained
this i believe with some um
some policy gradient algorithm
and they applied this actually to the
maze navigation problem that i mentioned
at the beginning
and in particular they wanted to learn
how to visually navigate different
mazes and with the goal of being able to
kind of quickly learn how to navigate a
new maze at test time
so they trained it on a thousand small
mazes
and then evaluated on both held out
small mazes as well as
new larger bases as well
and so what this looks like is this is
it's collecting its kind of training
data in this first episode right here
and you can see that it's kind of
exploring this maze a bit
um going in this this image on the left
is kind of what it's observing and this
is the top-down view right here that
the agent doesn't get to see it explores
its environment for the first episode
and then after that it knows exactly how
to solve the task
so essentially after it's kind of
explored sufficiently it knows enough
about this maze or it's kind of
learned how to navigate this maze such
that
at the next episode when it holds over
the state of the attention
kind of like when transfers over the
information from the attention and the
one decompolations
it can um it can solve the task
uh immediately
and they also applied this to a larger
maze so here's one example
of it uh effectively learning how to
navigate a larger maze
and so we can see in this first episode
it is again
exploring the maze and learning
how to navigate this maze and then in
the second episode it can
it's kind of learned how to navigate
this particular maze such that it can go
directly to the goal
in the most efficient
so those are some of the qualitative
examples and then quantitatively they
evaluated
um the performance in the small in small
bases and large mazes
uh for the first episode and the second
episode
and what they find is that they're able
to do
um significantly better than a random
agent
their architecture is also significantly
better than using
an lstm and also they're able to kind of
significantly improve in the second
episode compared to the first episode
which means that it is actually kind of
learning something about that maze
and uh and solving it in fewer
time steps
okay um now one kind of quick digression
on this approach is kind of the
connection between these
methods and contextual policies um
and what i mean by contextual policy is
some is a policy that's conditioned on
some context omega
for example omega might be the position
that you want to like stack a block in
or maybe the direction that you want a
robot to walk in
um and in many ways you could actually
view
this uh kind of a contextual policy in
some ways kind of as a special case
of these kinds of models um
where basically the the experience or
the data is serving as
context to the policy
uh yeah and then this kind of this last
part of the recurrent network is is the
actual policy part
um so you can essentially just view
these this kind of metal
method as a contextual policy with
experience or data as context
um and also if i'm not sure if it was
if goal conditioned rl and goal
condition value functions or universal
value functions were covered
um but you can also view this sort of
metal learning method as a way to adapt
to different goals
but in a more general way so rewards
allow you to actually adapt to any task
even if that task isn't a goal reaching
task and so in that way kind of these
rewards are a strict generalization of
goal-based tasks
um also in meta-rl you're typically
adapting to new tasks rather than trying
to generalize
in zero shot to new goals so that's kind
of another distinction with goal
condition
policies is that you're adapting in k
shot versus generalizing to a goal in
zero shot
okay um so
any questions on the
on this part
so it looks like there's a question
about um the maze navigation task from
uh sumana who says that how is the base
navigation task meta because we're
learning to navigate based on visual
representations
where size in the sha and shape might
not matter
um so in this case the uh the kind of
size and the shape of the
maze basically the shape of the maze
affects your strategy for navigating
that maze
um in some ways you can
there's i think that there's kind of
gray areas between things that are metal
learning and things that are just kind
of learning a policy
and recurrent networks are one thing
that kind of blur this line a little bit
um but the basically in this context you
basically need to adapt with data and
experience in this maze in order to do
well
and that's exactly why we saw that we
saw this kind of significant improvement
quantitatively between the first episode
and the second episode
uh tommy do you have your hand up do you
want to ask a question
uh can you hear me yeah um
so in meta rl setup we first
collect some context data from a set of
calls
from some some kind of policy so my
question is can you collect the
construct
context data on an online setup my like
not stopping
the collection procedure but continuing
online and collecting data on the go
yeah that's a good question so it's
actually worth mentioning that in
in these kinds of approaches it is
actually in a very online setting
where you're actually collecting data
and also predicting how to act
and by training this this kind of um
this recursive neural network model it's
actually being trained to
um kind of continuously collect data and
when it feels like it knows enough
information about the task it will stop
exploring
and simply just kind of take actions
that give it to the goal
so this is actually really in kind of an
online sort of setting
um i'm going to ask one more question
that's actually in the q a that's asking
about this paper by chad at all that
showed that
um that kind of representation learning
and metric learning kinds of approaches
uh can reach kind of performance that's
very similar to that of a meta learning
approach
the question is i wonder if we should
still focus on metal learning and one of
the things that i'll mention is that i
think that the the tasks that are
looking
looking at in that paper uh and actually
i think that may the findings of that
paper are specific to the image
classification setting
um and i think that in those settings
just learning good features is good
enough to solve those
those sets of tasks whereas i think that
in other kinds of metal learning task
distributions including in the
reinforcement learning setting
learning good features isn't enough to
be able to adapt to the task you need to
be able to explore effectively
and and adapting to the data that you've
collected during exploration
also requires a more sophisticated
adaptation procedure than simply doing
linear regression on top of features
okay um i'll hold off on questions for
now
uh to try to get through a little bit
more content
so this was um
kind of what i call a black box approach
in the sense that you're parameterizing
your network with
your parameterizing your learner with
this big neural network
and some of the benefits of this
approach is that it's quite general
uh and also very expressive a recurrent
neural network can approximate
any uh any function
under kind of fairly mild assumptions
and so we can really approximate
um any sort of learning procedure here
further there's also a variety of design
choices in the architecture which gives
you some flexibility in terms of how you
want it to actually process the data
now the downside to this approach is
that it's
a pretty complex model that has a has to
learn a very complex thing which is
learning from data
it has to actually be able to process
this data and actually kind of translate
that data into something
information about the task that informs
it about how to act in the future
and as a result because it has to learn
this pretty complex task
completely from scratch it can sometimes
be quite difficult to train these models
and sometimes they also require a fairly
impractical amount of data
in order to optimize them effectively
um so some of that motivates the next
class of approaches that we'll looked at
which is
optimization-based approaches and the
kind of
starting point for optimization-based
meta-learning is this idea of
fine-tuning
so the way that fine-tuning works is you
have a set of pre-trained parameters
theta
and you run gradient descent on those
pre-trained parameters
using training data for a new task for
example you might pre-train some neural
network parameters on the data set like
imagenet
and then fine-tune parameters on a more
modestly sized data
set for some new tasks that you care
about to get some parameters fi that
work well
for that new task so
this works actually quite well um and
people have shown actually a lot of
success
of this in computer vision settings but
also in natural language settings as
well
uh and we'd like to be able to extend
this to the fuchsia learning setting
now unfortunately if you pre-train on
something like imagenet and then
fine-tune on only a few examples
it's likely not to work very well and
you're likely to over fit to those small
examples to that small data set
and so instead what we're going to try
to do is explicitly
optimize for a set of pre-trained
parameters such that fine-tuning
works well and so the way that you can
write this out is something like this
where you're going to have some set of
pre-trained parameters theta
you're going to run one or a few steps
of gradient descent
from those parameters on your new task
and then optimize for the performance of
those fine-tuned parameters
on held out data and you'll do this
not just for one task but you'll do this
for all of the tasks in your metatrading
set
such that you could hopefully transfer
to a new task
so essentially you're kind of like
embedding grading descent into this meta
learning process
and specifically optimizing for your
initial pre-trained parameters
so this kind of key idea is to learn
this initial set of parameters or these
initial features
that transfer effectively with a small
number of gradient steps and a small
amount of data
so let's look at a kind of an
illustrative example
or actually let's first look at a
diagram of kind of what this looks like
visually
so say that theta is the parameter
vector that you're meta learning
and phi i star is the optimal parameter
vector for task i
then you can view the meta trading
processes this thick black line here
and what is trying to do is if you're at
kind of this point in the meta training
process and you take a gradient step
with respect to task three
you're quite far from the optimum for
task three and likewise for the other
tasks
but at the end of the metatrading
process if you take a grading step with
respect to task three you are
close to the optimum and likewise if you
take a gradient step for task one or for
task two
so this is kind of a kind of more
conceptual diagram for what this is
trying to do
it's trying to get to you is kind of
just set in the parameter space that
allows you to quickly
fine tune to um the optimal parameter
vector for a different task
um so this algorithm is called model
agnostic metal learning
and it's an example of one optimization
based metal learning algorithm and there
are kind of
other ways that you can twist this such
you can learn the learning rate here for
example or you could use
other inner optimizations not just
gradient descent
and in the context of reinforcement
learning what this might look like is
trying to learn a set of initial
features or a representation space
under which reinforcement learning is
very quick
um so as kind of an illustrative example
say you want this
uh quadruped ant agent to run
in different directions and you meditate
it to be able to run in those different
directions
at the end of the mediterranean
procedure but before you take a gradient
step
you get a policy that looks like this
essentially the um the ant is
essentially like running in place it's
kind of ready to run
in any given direction if you then take
a gradient step
one gradient step with respect to the
task of running backward
you get a policy that looks like this
that runs backward
and if you take one gradient step with
respect to the task of
running forward you get a policy that
looks like this
and this is just kind of with a with
just a single gradient step
okay so that's kind of the intuition
behind this kind of approach
now what does this look like on a more
realistic task distribution not just
where you want to run in different
directions but when you want to adapt to
different scenarios
so we can combine this approach with a
model based reinforcement learning
setting
where we want to be able to adapt to
different dynamics in the environment
and in particular we want to be able to
adapt completely online
and what we're going to do is we're
going to store our recent history
we're then going to adapt to those last
m time steps
using just one step of gradient descent
on your learn dynamics model
and then we'll get our updated model
parameters and run planning
or model predictive control npc which is
kind of
a fancy word to say that we're going to
be planning um at each time seth
using this model uh take it action in
the environment then add this and then
kind of continue to adapt our model
and take actions under the adapted model
now of course if you start from scratch
and adapt your model with one gradient
step you won't do very well
so what we do is we meta train this
agent to be able to adapt to different
dynamics
using the mammal or the modeling gnostic
metal learning algorithm and train it
such that it can adapt with just a
single gradient step
okay so this is kind of one example of
being able to adapt to different
dynamics
some examples of dynamics variation
might be if you [ __ ] the leg
of an agent or you their agent needs to
kind of run across some platforms and
the platforms have different buoyancy
kind of like a pure um and if you're on
just kind of standard model based rl in
these environments without any
adaptation
you get behavior that looks like this so
the videos are a bit um are a bit shaky
but
so as soon as the the
lag is crippled the agent isn't able to
move very far and
uh in this case when it's trained on
these different platforms with different
buoyancy
uh the cheetah isn't able to figure out
how to effectively
navigate this terrain and eventually
flips over
however if we combine this with a metal
learning approach
and train it to quickly adapt online to
these dynamic changes
it can figure out how to essentially
adapt
uh online to
changes such as a crippled leg or um or
these varying
buoyancy uh these platforms with varying
buoyancy
okay um and because this is actually a
model based
uh meta rl approach it's actually quite
efficient in comparison to model three
approaches
and that means that it's actually quite
practical to run it on a real robot
so we took the same algorithm we
collected data of this robot this legged
velociraptor robot on different terrains
on turf on styrofoam on carpet
and we trained it to be able to quickly
adopt a dynamics model using mammal to
these different terrains
um and there's more than just these
three three trains there was about i
think 10 trains in the data set
and then we wanted to evaluate to
different different other changes and
dynamics such as the robot being on a
slope
missing one of its legs having a payload
or having calibration errors
and in this case the first example is we
put the the robot on the slope
and if you just treat it with model
based rl
which doesn't have the ability to adapt
it isn't able to
effectively walk in a straight line up
the slope and ends up gearing up to the
right
whereas by using metal learning it's
able to adapt
online to these to the change in
dynamics caused by the slope
and able to effectively make it to the
top of the slope
in kind of roughly a straight line
and then in this last example we
actually took off the front right leg of
the robot
uh if you train this with model based rl
it isn't because it's kind of lost its
front right leg it veers off to the
right
and if you actually trade it to adopt
using metal learning
is able to adapt and learn how to learn
this new dynamics model
online and effectively follow the
straight line
okay cool so
there's essentially these two different
kinds of meta reinforcement learning
methods
one is these black box methods where the
neural network is implementing this
learned learning procedure
and then second is these optimization
based metal learning methods
where you're kind of embedding gradient
descent into
your learning procedure
now you can essentially view them as
very similar kinds of approaches they
kind of both take this form f
but the key difference with the
optimization based metal earner is that
inside this function f we have this
gradient operator that is
updating our parameters as a function of
the training data set rather than just
ingesting that training data into a
neural network
um so as i mentioned before some of the
benefits of the black box approach is
that it's quite general and expressive
there's also a variety of design choices
in architecture but
it can be challenging to train whereas
an optimization based method
it's usually typical typically easier to
train because you have this inductive
bias of sgd built in
kind of at initialization is already
doing some amount of learning with
gradient descent
it's also model agnostic and so if you
have an architecture already
it's fairly easy to plug and play with
your existing architecture
um the downside is that sometimes with
reinforcement learning methods
the gradient that you get from a
reinforcement learning method like a
policy gradient or gradient of bellman
error
are often not very informative about the
data and so sometimes it can actually be
challenging to combine this approach
combine kind of an optimization based
approach with policy gradients for
example
if the gradients you're getting are very
noisy or high variance
okay so this is a good point to pause
for questions
toga do you want to ask your question
yep thank you um so the the image
in in describing the model agnostic uh
metal learner
paper was quite illustrative um to my
understanding
what it does is that it learns kind of
their generalizable
task invariant parameters which kind of
call like
i i think in a sense um it's uh we're
trying to find
better priors so that
for a specific test it just uses that
prior to generalize well do you think
there's some
sense of bayesian methods uh to be
explored in that direction because um
having a prior um immediately suggests
that maybe it's a bayesian learning
scheme yeah that's a great question
so it turns out that you could actually
show
that with some fairly crude
approximations that mammal is actually
approximating
uh kind of um the inference procedure in
a hierarchical bayesian model
where the where the gradient step is
doing something that looks like
uh kind of posterior inference
and the kind of metal learning process
is learning
uh the prior in that model um so there's
works on
air by aaron grant on that and there's
also some works um
by myself and by others that actually
try to
make these methods more basin
essentially uh and a key component of
that is to
when estimating your posterior of your
task parameters
actually representing a distribution
over parameters or a distribution
over functions um that quantify your
hypotheses about
what the correct function is for that
task um
as a quick follow-up uh do you think
there's some sort of
uh parallelism between you know how a
neural networks early layers
learn kind of more general
representations and it just proceeds to
more specific
features versus um meta learner learning
kind of tasking variant generalizable
representations and we kind of fine-tune
it for uh
test specific features do you think
there's some sort of
one-to-one correspondence between these
two
um potentially i mean in some tasks we
find that we actually only need to
fine-tune the later layers
uh and the kind of the earlier layers
are more general and they don't need to
be fine-tuned
um in other tasks we do actually find
that the low-level features do actually
need to be adapted
um and uh need to be kind of adapted
to be like more task specific
should be do you want to ask your
question
yeah i had a question on whether um
there exists methods
to evaluate the degree of overlapping
substructure between tasks
um so that we can ensure that the policy
transfers um well at test time
i see so you're trying to you're trying
to think about
what um how tasks share structure
in a way um right so i would imagine
that
the the dataset that we sort of create
for um
training a meta learner um they
should have some degree of overlapping
substructure so for example in the case
of the maze
um i guess like we we deployed the agent
in another maze that shared mostly the
same features
at test time um but are there like
i guess methods to evaluate um how much
substructure
or like how much overlapping
substructure attached should have
yeah that's a really good question um i
think that that
there are perhaps some works but it's
also quite a challenging
thing to do especially with neural
networks where it's a little bit hard to
interpret exactly how they're
learning things and how they're sharing
structure across tasks
there is an approach called modular meta
learning that tries to actually
make this more explicit and more
interpretable and they actually are they
kind of learn how to combine different
modules and show which modules are
shared with between which tasks
i see okay cool
thanks uh how about one more question
from farshid
can you hear me yeah hello okay
so uh the um first order
metal learning optimization based ones
like
reptile they are not that much away from
mammals so what are your take on that so
why is that
why simply aggregating the
weights could do as as much um
could perform as much as like mammal so
how come yeah so as background for other
people
the um there's kind of you can construct
i guess
first the one thing you might notice in
the mammal objective
is that there is a gradient operator
inside here and you're also minimizing
over theta
so when you use um like sgd on this
objective overall
there actually are second order
derivatives that show up
as a kind of by nature of having a
gradient here
and a gradient here and you can derive a
first order
version of this algorithm by simply
dropping
all of the second order components and
other and
otherwise maintaining the um kind of
the gradient of this meta objective um
and then there's also another algorithm
called reptile that's actually very
similar to the first order version of
mammal
um and then the question is why does why
do those first order methods work well
um we observed this in the original
manual paper as well
uh for some of the few shot image
classification tasks
uh and for those tasks i mean the short
answer is we don't exactly know
it's actually not at all principled to
drop those second components the second
order components and we've actually
found that they aren't really close to
zero either
um but we also have observed that in
some more challenging tasks like fu shot
imitation learning
using a first order thing doesn't work
at all so i think that it has to do with
the nature of the task and how well
conditioned
this optimization problem is to be able
to ignore those second order
um second order terms um i think that in
some of the simpler kind of shot image
classification problems it's okay to
drop it but in other ones it's not
thanks thank you
okay great so for the sake of time
let's move on um
so maybe i'll just
go here so we talked a bit about the
pros and cons now what i'd like to focus
on
is this problem of learning how to
explore essentially how should we
collect d trade
so so far we've kind of largely haven't
been kind of thinking about this problem
at all we've just been collecting d
train according to our kind of current
policy or current model
um and this is reflective of kind of the
standard solution to this problem which
is to simply optimize
for exploration and execution of the
task
end to end with respect to the reward of
your
execution performance uh and this is the
approach that's taken by
kind of a wide range of papers in better
reinforcement learning
it's simple which is nice it also in
principle will lead to the
the optimal strategy for exploring
however the downside for this approach
is that it can actually be a quite
difficult optimization problem
when exploration is difficult for a new
task
so what i'll briefly talk about is some
alternative solutions for solving this
problem
and actually first i'll explain in what
scenarios this might be a challenging
optimization problem
so let's look at an example of a hard
exploration problem
so say we want a robot chef that can
cook for us
and what we do is we kind of meditate it
across these different kitchens maybe
kind of we have a few different kitchens
in a factory and we trade it to be able
to adapt to those different kitchens
and then after it kind of does its
metatrading in the factory we then kind
of ship out the robot
and deploy it into your own kitchen and
you want the robot to be able to
learn how to perform cooking tasks in
your own kitchen
now this is a pretty challenging problem
because uh
in order to learn how to cook you need
to figure out where all the utensils are
or where all the
ingredients are um and you also need to
kind of figure out that
exploration of the of everything in your
kitchen doesn't necessarily matter like
looking at the decorations
um isn't really helpful for learning how
to
solve cooking leg tasks uh so we'll be
doing mediterranean across these
previous kitchens
and then at meta test time we're going
to be given
at least one exploration episode to kind
of learn where all the
ingredients are and then one execution
episode that leverages that exploration
information to
perform these cooking tests
okay so here's kind of a running
canonical example
now why is end-to-end training of
exploration hard
um so the reason why this is hard is we
have a bit of a chicken and egg problem
which is that we need to do two things
we need to learn how to find the
ingredients or we need to learn how to
explore
and we need to learn how to cook and
if you have a bad exploration policy if
you can't find ingredients
that it's going to be very difficult to
learn how to cook you're going to have
kind of
a heart really hard time learning how to
execute tasks
and further if you don't know how to
cook things um you have a bad kind of
execution strategy
then any exploration policy that you try
will have low reward simply because you
can't cook
and so this leads to this kind of
coupling problem where
learning exploration depends on having a
good execution strategy and learning
execution depends on
knowing how to explore so
let's think about some kind of
alternative solutions rather than an
end-to-end approach
to allow us to solve this coupling
problem
so the first solution we'll look at is
leveraging alternative exploration
strategies rather than trying to learn
them end to end
and what this might look like is one
alternative strategy would be to use
posterior sampling which is also called
thompson sampling
this is the approach that was taken in
the pearl paper
and what this looks like is first you
learn a distribution
over a latent variable that represents
your task
and this distribution is either
conditioned on no data if you don't have
any data yet
or is conditioned on the data that
you've collected so far
and then you also learn a corresponding
policy for
that task and then once you have these
the way that you can explore
is simply to sample z from your current
posterior hence the name posterior
sampling
and sample from your policy for that
task
uh and then kind of iteratively reapply
the sampling procedure by
kind of iteratively sampling from the
environment
and recomputing your posterior
so the way that this looks like in
practice is say you have a simple
task distribution which is to navigate
to these different goal
positions shown as these light blue
circles and maybe in this instance the
actual task
is to go to this blue dark blue circle
here
and for each of these tasks you only get
a reward if you're within the circle
now if you sample some trajectories from
your prior over tasks you'll get
trajectories that are going to
different circles and then
you can then take this data and then
update your post year
and then kind of re-sample tractories
that will bring you to positions that
are different from the things that you
saw before
so these are shown in the lighter pink
color
and then using this data you can then
update your posterior again and because
you had one trajectory that reached the
goal
your posterior should now focus on this
goal and that's exactly what we see here
where the rest of your data is going to
the goal
so this is um this is one
one way to explore one strategy to
explore this can be
quite effective um but it may also not
be optimal in some cases
so it may not be optimal for example if
your goals are very far away
and maybe there's a sign on the wall
that tells you what is the correct goal
posterior sample sampling will never
actually look at that sign
it will never actually go out of its way
to look at that sign it will simply
sample goals
whereas the optimal exploration strategy
would just be to look at that sign and
then go to the correct goal
okay so that's one approach another
approach is to use kind of intrinsic
rewards or some kind of self-supervised
objective to
explore that's what's done in this paper
uh and the last strategy might be
to try to explore such that you can
effectively predict the dynamics
and the reward for each task and that
was what was done in the medicare paper
and the way this looks like is you would
train a model of your
dynamics and your reward conditioned on
your experience
and then try to collect experience so
that this model
is accurate and in the same environment
that i mentioned before we actually see
that a strategy like this will actually
learn a better exploration strategy
where it
actually kind of moves around the circle
rather than sampling
uh more inefficiently but this may not
this well this is kind of much more
effective in this environment
it may not be optimal in other
environments
for example if you have a lot of
distractors in the environment or if you
have very complex and high dimensional
state dynamics
then learning this model will be very
difficult
okay so the pros of this these kinds of
approaches is that they're very easy to
optimize
and many of them are actually based on
very principled strategies for example
in posterior sampling you could actually
quantify
how optimal this is but they can be
sub-optimal by arbitrarily large amounts
in some environments
okay so the last approach that we'll
look at for solving the exploration
strategy
is to try to decouple exploration and
exploitation
or an execution by acquiring
representations
of task relevant information and kind of
the key idea is if we can acquire this
representation of what's relevant to the
task
we can then explore in a way that allows
us to recover that information
so the way that we do this is we first
to learn we first learn this
representation of
the key information for the task and
then learn to explore by recovering that
information
so to do this first step we condition
on an identifier of the kitchen this
could be an identifier that looks like
this that identifies like the wall color
the ingredients and the decoration
it could also just be a one hot
identifier for the kitchen
and you train an execution policy
conditioned on
this this identifier of the task
and critically we also bottleneck this
representation
using an information bottleneck to
encourage it to discard
parts of this task identifier or bits of
this task identifier
that aren't relevant for actually
solving the task
so that we don't care about the
decorations here we mostly just care
about where the ingredients
are and then once we learn this
execution policy
which we can do with simple standard rl
we can then
train an exploration policy to produce
exploration episodes that recover this
information captured in z
by maximizing information gain at each
time step
and then i'm at a test time we can
deploy this exploration strategy which
will produce an exploration episode that
has the right information
which can then be passed to the
execution policy
okay um so we'll call this decoupled
reward free exploration and execution
in meta earl or dream um
it actually turns out that you can prove
that this approach
is actually consistent with the
end-to-end objective
um so this will actually recover the
optimal exploration strategy
if provided enough data
okay oh and it's also worth mentioning
that this approach will also in
principle be significantly more
efficient than the end-to-end approach
because you aren't
um because you're kind of decoupling
this these this
uh decoupling the exploration execution
phases
so if we look at a challenging 3d visual
navigation problem
um in this case unlike the other tasks
the the goal will be to learn to go to a
certain
key block or ball of a certain color and
the color will be specified by the sign
here
and the agent will start over here such
that actually has to walk around the
barrier
and go to the side to kind of read what
color object it should go to
and this is all with pixel observations
and as far as reward
and what we find is with this approach
here it is able to learn to kind of go
around the barrier
and go and read the sign during the
exploration episode
so this is something that you wouldn't
get from posterior sampling
and it's also something that would be
very difficult to learn end to end
when you have visual observations and
sparse rewards
and then in the execution episode um it
figures out that it should go
to um it's kind of given that it should
go to the key
and because it figured out that you have
the blue key it's able to immediately go
to the blue key
and then if you look at kind of average
return this approach is able to do
um achieve like pretty near optimal
reward um these existing end-to-end
approaches do very poorly because
exactly because of this coupling problem
it's very hard to learn this exploration
strategy
end to end and then uh
thompson sampling achieves uh
would achieve something like this pink
line here so essentially this is an
upper bound on how well the pearl
algorithm would do
okay um so kind of to summarize how we
might learn how to explore there's this
end-to-end approach
which can lead to the optimal
exploration strategy and principle but
it is very hard to optimize
when exploration is hard alternative
strategies are easy to optimize
and many of them are based on principled
strategies but they can be sub-optimal
in some environments
and then if we use this decoupled
approach at least the optimal strategy
in principle
it's also easy to optimize in practice
and one downside is that it does require
this task identifier to identify
kind of a one-hot id that identifies the
task
however in practice this identifier is
is typically pretty easy to get
okay um so for the sake of time i think
i should skip
questions here and try to start to wrap
up and talk about some of the challenges
and latest developments in meta-rl
so what are the open challenges in
better reinforcement learning
so the first one that i would say is
trying to figure out how to adapt
to entirely new tasks
so before i showed how we could adapt to
different dynamics models like different
terrains for example
or adapt to running in different
directions or different mazes
but in many situations we may want to
adapt to something that's kind of more
distinctly different from what's in the
meta training set um
and if we want to be able to do this
something to kind of adapt to something
that's quite distinct
we need to still follow this kind of
guiding principle of machine learning in
general
which is that the things we see at
training should the distribution of
things that we see at training should
match the distribution of things that we
see at testing
and so if we want to adapt to something
completely new this means that
our task distribution needs to be quite
broad
so that when we kind of see something
new that's still within this broad
distribution of tasks
okay so how do we where do we actually
get this broad distribution of tasks
um we could look to existing rl
benchmarks but things like open eye gym
or the atari benchmark they aren't
particularly suitable
for this either because the tasks are
quite different from one another
or there's aren't enough tasks to
actually support generalization to new
tasks
so with this in mind we actually
recently developed a benchmark for
studying this problem that we called the
meta world benchmark
and it has actually 50 tasks from pretty
distinct
manipulation settings um where the goal
is to kind of manipulate an object in a
new way or
like kind of manipulate something in the
environment
and uh kind of this satisfied a number
of
designerada that we think should make it
effective for studying metal learning
algorithms
including 50 qualitatively distinct
tasks um
a shaped reward function for each of the
tasks so that you don't have to worry
about rl
failing on these tasks you just can
focus on the transfer problem
um and it does have a unified state and
action space to help facilitate transfer
as well
um and it turns out if you actually
apply metal learning algorithms existing
metal learning algorithms to this
benchmark
they don't they don't do very well um at
all it's challenging to
scale approaches to this so far um so
that's kind of a
good open challenge for for the field
um cool another
challenge is figuring out robustness to
our distribution tasks
so many times the task that you want to
be able to transfer to is a little bit
different than what you saw during
metatrading
um and you want to be able to robust be
robust to that and
this there's been some initial work at
this in the supervised learning setting
uh but to find knowledge no one has
looked at this in the meta reinforcement
learning setting
the third open challenge in my mind is
figuring out where the tasks should even
come from
uh essentially
the we need to somehow define these
tasks for metatrading and
we kind of metal learning algorithms
assume that these tasks are given
but this means that a human or something
needs to provide them to the agent
and kind of so far we looked at manually
defined distributions of tasks and
correspond
and corresponding rewards uh but it'd be
nice to actually have
mechanisms for the algorithm itself to
come up with tasks for itself to solve
um and kind of one initial approach to
this would be to try to take some skill
discovery methods which learn
different skills and then perform better
learning across these skills to be able
to adapt to a new skill
um and there's been some promising
approaches promising results with this
approach compared to
simply learning from scratch uh but i
think that there's kind of still
a lot of work to be done on that front
uh and then lastly also just
uh i think that the reinforcement
learning algorithms that
we that metal rl algorithms build on uh
is really
a core aspect of them if the rl
algorithm isn't very good then the meta
rl algorithm also won't be very good
uh so i think that we need to continue
to improve the stability and
effectiveness
of rl algorithms themselves
okay um so one key takeaway if you kind
of learn nothing
from this talk the one thing that i
think you should kind of take away is
that
we should start i think moving away from
reinforcement learning from scratch
and meta rl provides one approach to do
this but not the only approach
um in the slides i put a bunch of
references
for other works or some of the works
that i covered today that i think
can be helpful if you're interested in
learning more about some of these topics
i underlined some of the ones that i
think are some of the key references for
learning about some of these different
topics
and i'll leave this in the slides for
you to take a look at as
as much as you're interested in and also
it's worth mentioning that i
teach a course at stanford on metal
learning um
and all the lecture videos are available
online uh this was a bit of a kind of a
whirlwind of meta reinforcement learning
the course goes in more depth and um and
goes a bit slower than
what you can cover in a one hour lecture
great so i'd be happy to take a couple
more questions and we also have the
breakout session
at um in a few minutes as well
do you wanna hand yeah go ahead
uh thank you uh i really enjoyed the
talk i have
a sort of basic question which it's sort
of related to the
uh open-ended questions that you put up
about where do these tasks come from
so my question is how do you decide on
the number of
training tasks and um
have you do you have any initial results
on
if you just keep supplying your metal
learning algorithm with more data
do the results just keep getting better
and better or they peak or plateau
is there any analysis done on that
yeah that's a great question so um
typically you want
a fair number uh a decently large number
of tasks
um basically the more tasks you like
having more tasks will allow you to kind
of generalize
to new tasks better similar to in
machine learning having more data allows
you to generalize to new data points
well as well
um as kind of a concrete example
typically
um in kind of meta supervised learning
settings
we'll assume that we have like at least
50 to 100 tasks um
although the more you have the better of
course and like with the omniglot data
set for example you actually have more
like a thousand tasks
um and in these reinforcement learning
settings we also
typically look at a similar number of
tasks around the order of 50 to 100.
okay thank you
yeah and actually oh the second part of
your question was like how do they keep
on getting better as you give them more
data yeah
i would say that as you give them more
tasks they definitely keep on getting
better
um at least from what i've seen although
as i mentioned kind of like having these
very broad task distributions are still
a big challenge for these these
algorithms and in our experiences
okay so they don't really uh they don't
um generalize
well yet to uh something that is
extremely out of distribution right
yeah okay um although one thing i will
say is that gradient-based methods tend
to generalize better than black box
methods
because you're still at least running
gradient descent whereas if you just
kind of apply a neural network to
out-of-distribution training data then
there's really
nothing you can ex you can't necessarily
expect it to generalize to anything out
of distribution
but like you you don't even know if it's
going to improve on like the training
loss on that data
whereas with gradient descent you at
least know that given kind of out of
distribution data
it will at least do as well as like fine
tuning for example
awesome thank you great um
do you want to ask a question
yeah sure uh thanks thanks for the talk
first and um
my question is about i'm new to the math
and learning
perspective so my um it feels like the
mental learning problem is more like a
learning to generalize
so my question is about is there any way
for us to
measure the generalization gap between
different distributions of tasks
yeah and also like something
if there are something like the pipe
learning framework course to
quantize and do some theoretical
analysis on this
problem yeah so you can you can
definitely view metal learning as trying
to
learn to generalize with a small amount
of data
um and ultimately hope to kind of
generalize to new tasks
there is a little bit of theoretical um
there is definitely some theoretical
work on trying to quantify like the
distance between tasks and
transferability between tasks
for example there's some work by
alessandro chile who
recently completed his phd at
ucla i believe with with stefano suado
on trying to kind of build some
theoretical
framework between transfer
transferability between tasks
um i've yet to see like a theoretical
like i think that that
alessandra's work is is quite
interesting but i've yet to see a
framework that's really
um in practice like effective at
informing
transferability and so forth i think
that part of the challenge is that the
transferability between tasks depends
very much on the model and set of
features and what you've already learned
for example if you know things about um
about physics then
or maybe if you know things about um
yeah if you
if you know certain things then kind of
two tasks might be more similar to each
other versus if you don't know
some kind of common factor then they
might look very different
yeah i'm just wondering if we can have a
more principle way of
instead of random search on designing
the model architectures as you said
the task data distribution matters a lot
and also the multi-modal
architectures matters a lot so yeah
yeah i definitely think that they're
like at least right now it's more of a
kind of an empirical study of what can
transfer and what can't
um another way to look at it that we a
perspective that we took in the meta
world paper is that you can have kind of
parametric variability of tasks where
there's some underlying parameter that's
continuously varying
and non-parametric variability where you
kind of have things that aren't
multiple tasks that kind of don't lie on
this single continuous spectrum
but i think there's kind of a lot of
work to be done to try to formalize
things that are
useful in practice yeah i totally agree
with that
especially the earlier of the parametric
meta world model so maybe in the next
time
the next step would also be to like uh
learn the parametric real-world tasks
learn to parametrize the real-world task
distribution
yeah yeah thank you okay maybe we take
one more quick question from henry
can you hear me okay yeah okay um so i
just had a question about how you
can kind of formally define distances or
similarities between types of
tasks so whether there's kind of like a
strict metric or like formal metric that
you have over task space to
kind of determine how similar tasks are
the agent can solve or
how different two tasks are that an
agent might be able to solve
yeah so this is kind of getting at what
um what john was asking
uh i think that there aren't really i
think that such a metric would need to
depend on the model that you've
currently learned
um one metric is basically just how well
fine tuning works
like if if you fine tune does that lead
to good performance
um when you kind of pre-train on one
task and transfer to another task
uh but i think that there aren't really
any
any metrics that people have come up
with that um
that are kind of useful in practice and
uh
yeah and like theoretically grounded
okay thank you okay
i think we're at the four o'clock mark
thank you so much
uh chelsea i know you wanted to get as
many questions answered as possible
the good news is is that uh we will be
having a breakout session with chelsea
in roughly what 10 to 15 minutes and
we're carrying
over those questions to continue the
conversation
thank you so much uh i wanted to close
off
uh the the conference because it was our
last lecture of the five
day deep learning reinforcement learning
summer school thank you all thank you
chelsea thank you to all of the other
speakers
on behalf of seafarer on behalf of mila
i want to thank you for joining us
and i do want it because i did get a
couple of questions on this
i do want to tell you that the slack
channel that has been
buzzing with the interaction is going to
be open
until the end of the month so more
questions more interactions with
speakers between each other
uh keep at it because it will be
available until the end of
august um it's not over yet
we have the breakout sessions and lastly
we were going to laugh
with ai improv at five o'clock so don't
miss it
uh hosted by amy institute so let's take
a quick break
give chelsea a moment to catch her
breath
and head over to the breakout sessions
the links are on the daily agenda
thank you all so much it has been a
pleasure
bye everyone